so here's the craziest thing about uh
what you were just talking about off
camera you just got into this
summer of 2020. it's not like you've
been a
true believer from day one it's not like
you bought in you know 12 years ago 10
years ago when these guys are talking
you just got in two years ago for a guy
as smart as you what made you switch and
say this is the way to go
um
you know most people don't think about
money
and uh we just kind of take it for
granted and and i uh really took it for
granted up until about 2020 but i think
in march of 2020 a lot of people's
world's view world views were shaken
right i had some deeply held beliefs you
know one belief is
everybody should work in an office and
you had to come show up and work in the
office and then during the lockdowns
i i found that i had to question that
belief and pretty soon we're all working
remotely and and i along with probably a
billion other people went through that
same transformation so that was like a
digital transformation of work
uh in uh in the second quarter of 2020
we had what we'll call a
k-shape recovery but in my opinion the
k-shape recovery was main street got
shut down and locked down and if you
manufactured anything or provided
services your business was wrecked
and then wall street had a rapid
miraculous recovery within six weeks of
the pandemic and they had the best year
of their life and
i could have basically
sat on a floatie in my you know poll in
the hamptons and got a 30 return
in that year doing nothing
which would be the best year of my
entire business career if i'm a
financier
but if i was running a restaurant or
running a manufacturing facility or
doing something with raw materials
i would have had to generate 30 more
cash flow to get nothing
you would have and of course that was
impossible so can you explain can you
flint to the average get what that means
30 more cash flow the value of the
currency collapsed in the year in
essence the fed printed 40 percent of
all the dollars in existence in the 18
months uh that followed the pandemic so
when jerome powell said we're not even
thinking about thinking about raising
interest rates you know and forecast
four years of zero percent interest
and when the fed loosened the reserve
restrictions on banks and allowed banks
to in essence print infinite money with
no reserve ratio
then uh
the economy was flooded with liquidity
what happened was the stock market
immediately recovered people thought
that that was a that was
something good
it wasn't good it was the money
collapsing it was the value of the
dollar collapsing in real time against
scarce assets
so i most of the time if you owned a
portfolio of stocks if you had a billion
dollars worth of stocks and your
portfolio went up by 30 you would have
thought you were a genius in that year
for doing what for staying invested in
stocks why
because jerome powell printed 30 more
money
okay
if you didn't own a portfolio of stocks
if you thought you were going to work as
a dentist or a doctor or do things with
in the real world
your business is shut down the cost of
all your materials is going up your
labor's disappeared and no one's showing
up to buy your stuff
the world doesn't look so good so you
had this uh
dichotomy i think and
the people on one side of of the economy
thought everything was just fine and
people on the other side of the economy
got destroyed
i was sitting in the middle i had a main
street company that generated 500
million in revenue and generated
cash flow
and i had a 500 million dollar treasury
that was sitting in conservative
instruments basically invested in in
short-dated uh
sovereign debt you know that that the
conventional strategy for any publicly
traded company is
you take your treasure and you buy one
to five year t bills
and otherwise hold it in cash
now um
if the if the
interest rates were three or four
percent and the money supply was
expanding at two percent you might think
that that was rational
when the interest rate goes to zero
percent and the money supply is
expanding at two or three percent it
looks a little bit painful
but when wall street recovers 30 percent
in a matter of weeks when main street's
completely shut down and it's pretty
obvious it's shut down
you're
you're
catalyzed to consider your premises
check your premises and ask the question
is the economy 30 better than it was
before the pandemic
or is there something else going on here
and i think the answer is there's
something else going on here the the
actual inflation rate isn't two percent
or zero percent the inflation rate was
30 percent but the inflation was hitting
the assets it wasn't hitting consumer
goods
and so
what i realized is maybe the money
supply is expanding faster than zero or
two percent a year and i started on a
search and i discovered the bitcoin
standard
and some austrian econ economists and
what i realized is the money supply
really been expanding at seven to ten
percent a year for the last decade
that's why the s p indexes is
appreciating it ten 10 a year for a
decade and once i realize that that
assets like the s p and equity
portfolios and real estate are driven
primarily by monetary policy of the
central banks
then i realized that holding money at
zero percent interest when the money
supply is expanding at 10 percent is
losing 10 percent of your wealth a year
and then i realized that in fact the
money supply was expanding not at 10
percent but about 25 a year starting
with the
pandemic
and i was going to lose half my wealth
on that treasury within 36 months
and once i realized that i was i was
destroying about 250 million dollars of
shareholder value if i did nothing i
started thinking i need to do something
so in an environment where where the
money is losing
15 20 25 of its value a year and you're
sitting in all cash
instruments you either need to give the
money back to the shareholders or you
need to invest it in some scarce
desirable asset so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye
[Music]